so let's talk about Michael Flynn this
We the People thing we did bring it up a
little bit yesterday so we'll we'll sort
of segue off this into Trump's call for
victory you know he's calling fiscos
he's calling us to give him the win
before we do man I'd even say this
subscribe hit the like button hit the
notification Bell you may have noticed
we changed the cameras a little bit Yeah
Yeah and we're going to change them a
little bit further we're just kind of
making things better and better as we go
along but again subscribe live Monday
through Friday at eight uh live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and again smash
the like button so check this out we
have this tweet
General Flynn Flynn uh said hashtag we
the people he tagged Sydney Powell and
wood dance Gavino Lou Dobbs Maria
bartaromo Mark Levin and who's low fly I
don't know who Lo fly is just uh oh okay
proud wife of an American hero and then
it is the press release from the We the
People convention if you didn't see this
yesterday this is a call for Donald
Trump to declare martial law
to enact a new election and a lot of
people are saying that's that's crazy
it's unconstitutional how would even do
this and what they're saying is Trump
needs to have a new election paper only
secure poll Watchers and all that stuff
I don't think I don't think it can be
done
right now
what the We the People convention are
saying is martial law is preferable to
Civil War
so they're they're basically saying if
Trump does nothing we're going to have
Civil War what's extremely likely well
if Trump declares martial law and says
Joe Biden didn't win then we're going to
have Civil War it's just there's no way
around that yeah I mean absolutely I
mean my my uh kind of pro my solution to
fix this problem is to I mean I don't
know why people aren't talking about
this let's break up the country and two
you like a government you like Joe Biden
stay on one place yeah I mean what what
the cities leave yeah no this represent
themselves and people who want to be
under one government will be under one I
think I mean I I think really we're
headed towards a very dangerous
situation and I think the only way to
avoid getting it it being even more uh
worse for everyone is to just simply
walk away from it I think we're out I
mean I guess we saw what John podesta
was suggesting that it would be better
for Joe Biden to uh for the west coast
to secede from the Union Yes than to
allow Donald Trump to win did you
invaded immediately if a city tried to
secede they'd get invaded by the United
States any any of those States tried to
secede oh absolutely to be occupied in
two seconds and then it would just like
there's actually been conservatives
calling for that saying remove the local
leadership the politicians and just put
it under like 10 territorial rule like
revoke their statehood and like it's
getting crazy out there man listen like
I I could understand why Michael Flynn
is retweeting you look you know you pull
up some of these websites and they're
like
Michael Flynn calls for martial law and
things like this it's like well they're
pushing this this idea you know we can
be careful in that I understand I
completely understand why Michael Flynn
would be saying this they they railroad
the guy they they threatened his family
plead guilty to this BS charge or we're
going to go after your kid and then when
when Trump got inside we're getting rid
of this they were like nah judge
Sullivan refused to allow them to drop
the case it makes no sense and then he
was sitting and waiting you know why
Sullivan was waiting and not just saying
fine we're going to roll on this because
he was just going to wait it out until
Biden gets in office and then say okay
we're back on track Flynn you're going
to prison so Trump issues that pardon
Flynn's livid and he says do it I get it
because he went through the corrupt
process and is there going to be Justice
should that shouldn't that judge face
some kind of censure or or impeachment
what about the what about the FBI agents
who who threatened his son and said
we're going to prosecute your son unless
you plead guilty all of them get away
with it so of course he's coming out and
saying Trump shut it down
yeah I mean Michael Flynn definitely
didn't have any friends in Washington DC
when he was coming into Power with
Donald Trump he's one of the few people
that actually whistleblowed on the U.S
agency
on the U.S agency's financing uh jihadis
in in Syria he's one of the few ones
that was inside of Obama's
administration that released information
and said it's because of Barack Obama
it's because of Hillary Clinton why we
have Isis and that was East and that was
retribution yes it exactly was right
there's no other way to to to really see
it because when Michael Flynn came out I
was talking about all the you know
important information he was you know
finally confirming because I've been
saying for a very long time especially
since there was this kind of quote
revolution in Syria this kind of
Liberation that Hillary Clinton was
supporting of the Syrian people when
that was happening I said wait wait wait
wait wait hold on why is Saudi Arabia
Israel the United States all working on
this one side why are the rebel groups
being financed and armed here who are
these Rebel groups they were al-nusra
they were Al-Qaeda and then they became
Isis as well that was Finance the only
person inside of the government that
actually confirmed it that actually
spoke out against it was Michael Flynn
Trump when Trump picked him to be a part
of his administration this is this was
one of the reasons I was like there
might be some legitimate change here
because Michael Flynn is at the helm of
National Security of American foreign
policy there's a chance that we finally
might revert some of the horrible
foreign policy Decisions by Hillary
Clinton then he didn't even get into
office because of why why because of the
Espionage Act an actor yeah yeah the
Logan act that wasn't used against
someone ever for for how long never
never exactly and and then his charge
officially was because Kushner told him
to contact Russia so Russia would vote
favorably with Israel no no no that's
that's not even that's not even it
there's an excuse you know uh based on
the notes that were released throughout
this investigation I think I think it
was coming from Durham I'm not entirely
sure no I don't think it was door I
don't know where these files were
released from it shows that it was
possibly Joe Biden who suggested the FBI
used the Logan act the Logan act
basically says that you as a
non-government agent can't act as though
you are representing the US government
it's never been used before because it's
a it was in it was written for a time
when there were no telephones now a guy
shows up and says hey I'm an ambassador
they call a number and says isn't it
he's not get out of here Michael Flynn
was the acting National Security advisor
for Donald Trump
he was coming in he had a phone call
with kislyak the Russian Ambassador and
he said don't please don't escalate
sanctions you know let us come in and
try and work things out that was it that
was his job he was supposed to do that
so they threatened him that's the Logan
act yep so they there was an informal
meeting with like hanging out of the
White House not a legitimate
investigation informal meeting and they
asked him do you ever talk to kislyak
and he said no no and they went got him
he lied they went to him and said can uh
confess plead guilty otherwise we will
go after your son notes that got
released from the FBI showed that the
agents were asking
what's our goal here to prosecute or get
him fired now why would the FBI just be
trying to get a guy fired this was
retribution from Barack Obama I didn't I
didn't know that about Flynn and smell
the beans and then it's very call us out
to understand here how the mainstream
media was reporting on this when it was
happening they were like confirmed
Russian collusion we have an active case
Michael Flynn deserves to go to jail I
mean what did Michael Flynn do he called
the Russian Ambassador right before
getting into Power while he was the
acting National Security yes I mean and
like Biden right now is calling up world
leaders talking to him if you're going
to charge Michael Flynn for that crime
you're gonna have to charge Joe Biden if
we're going by the law by the
definitions of how you enforce them so
that's something that people really can
kind of pay attention of course they're
not of course you know you have Joe
Biden literally studying up there
talking about you know all this nonsense
well literal president's elect behind us
isn't he getting a cat Joe Biden's
undoubted he's getting a cat a German
Shepherd look man Luke I I respect that
you're so passionate about you know
children being murdered and and and
Corruption at the highest levels and our
Patriots like Michael Flynn being
falsely targeted and imprisoned but I
think I need to point out Joe Biden was
playing with the dog you know he's got a
German Shepherd yeah yeah so dogs are so
great aren't they don't talk especially
nobody wants to hear this no no no go to
sleep I appreciate your life American
Gladiators and that you care about
people and want to protect people but
Biden is getting a cat yeah yeah I mean
that's what's more important here my one
of my favorite lines from uh uh uh who
I'm forgetting his name Bill Hicks Bill
Hicks here's American Gladiators what is
it here's 47 channels of it yep here's
uh you know distract yourself America uh
go back no no George Carlin also said go
back to sleep America because the only
way you could have the American dream is
is to be asleep Bill Hicks said go back
to bet America your government is in
control again yes yeah yeah amazing
comedians that that line sums up
everything that's happening I didn't
know that about Flynn yeah he's legit so
there's no wow dude he's he's a weird
character because he also has a very
strong kind of War policy towards Iran
yeah but when it came to being inside
the Obama Administration he's one of the
few people that actually spoke out
against some of the very wrong doings
that Obama was committing when he was
working for Obama I actually talked uh
to you know General Wesley Clark about
you know very these very kind of similar
issues and it's absolutely mind-boggling
to see how everything operates General
Leslie Clark was one of the few people
inside of the government that came out
on Democracy Now and talked about this
U.S plan for larger War right what do
you name like seven countries with seven
countries and U.S Libya Syria yeah U.S
foreign policy was literally wrong too
long or with it I talked to U.S general
Leslie Clark I was like you know thank
you so much for warning us about you
know this coming there was you know
something that didn't always you know
you weren't a true fortune teller but
most of what you said is coming true how
did you know what's going on are you
scared that you whistleblowed and and
talked about this plan for all these
wars he looked like he just saw a ghost
he turned white and he was like uh and
then he walked away and ran away and
didn't say anything and it was just
another awkward weird change kind of
interesting we have a lot of the Ambush
Ambush questions but they're trying to
put central banks in all these countries
is that what they're doing that's why
they went into Afghanistan but that's a
different Theory out there well now
there's central banks in Afghanistan and
Iraq um Iran doesn't have one Syria
didn't have one doesn't have one right
now Libya didn't now it does uh no Iran
doesn't have one so Uber doesn't have
one North Korea doesn't have one if if
one of the biggest uh uh one of the
talking points coming up now is that
everything Trump is doing with like the
dod and stuff is is an attempt to ramp
up going against Iran
yeah I mean uh start a war before you
leave or something yeah the Israeli
military there's scuttlebutt that
they're preparing for the U.S to you
know start a war with Iran but again
it's just scuttlebutt nothing has been
officially conferred we have seen very
aggressive moves by Donald Trump against
Iran that there's some people theorizing
that Donald Trump may start a conflict
with them to stay in power to stay in
power and all that I don't think that's
true I hope it's not true but again I
haven't seen it uh certified with any
legitimate information backing that just
a lot of speculation and theories but we
don't have to speculate we don't have to
theorize what's going to happen with Joe
Biden all you have to see is his whole
career in politics but also his actions
as vice president under Barack Obama who
made very telling statements today that
are absolutely mind-blowing I mean
there's another Madeleine Albright it
was worth it hundreds of thousands of
children died similar statement by
Barack Obama about this kind of
assassination program that he had which
is let me pull this up so I got this
tweet from Luke at Luke we are range
just a video of Obama explaining how he
had to stop himself from killing
innocent children this is from CBS it's
an interview with Stephen Colbert it
happened recently right it was a couple
days ago yes here's the best thing so
seeing this and seeing this interview I
thought wow there must have been a ton
of journalists who wrote this up like
look at what's going on but Joe Biden is
Obama 2.0 he's appointing a lot of the
same people it is going to be a disaster
so I Googled it and you know what I
found I Googled CBS drone Obama the rap
UFO yes Barack Obama knows the UFO
answer but he can't tell you
Obama Compares Trump to dictator okay
yes there you go it's absolutely
ridiculous but just to tell you what uh
Barack Obama said his exact quote was
the problem with the Drone program was
not that it caused an inordinate amount
of Civilian casualties
although even one civilian casualty is
tragic but the Drone probably had less
collateral damage and then he went on
and talked about how he was using this
and how there was a problem of how he
saw it as not even war and how he was
deploying it very casually without even
thinking about it and how he needed to
set up particular measures to stop
himself from sending out drone strikes
all over the world we have to understand
seven countries were attacked under the
uh Barack Obama administration Somalia
was also one of those heavily hit secret
war going on Somalia now apparently CA
agent died a terror attack well I was in
Somalia and uh I'll tell you what's
happening there is absolutely mind
boggling moggling I was able to talk to
victims of botched U.S raids where
innocent farmers were pretty much
assassinated because of bad Intel and
bad information now the the Somalia
conflict I mean we could do a full two
hours just about that in that issue
particularly but I just ended up there
randomly because Jeff Berwick the dollar
vigilante he's like an anarchist he he
keeps saying that everyone keeps
accusing him of of not being a real
Anarchist and if he is a real Anarchist
he should go to Somalia so he did so
he's like I'm gonna go to Somalia and he
was like you want to come I'm like yep
we went to Somalia and it was a surreal
experience and uh surprise surprise it
wasn't that there was a lack of
government the problem was that was that
there was too many governments inside
Somalia vying for power uh you know
Middle Eastern countries were involved
turkey was involved Qatar was involved
africom was involved the United States
was involved and they were all sending
in and shipping in weapons munition and
then soldiers that were hired that were
supposedly the good guys were started
selling them for food because they
didn't have food so it's a total
mismanagement and a total conundrum of
just absolutely what the hell is going
on when you go to Somalia when you talk
to some of these individuals they are
resilient they are amazing human beings
I was able to like talk to people who
were severely affected by Major
terrorist attacks by al-nusra by Major
attacks by the U.S military that killed
their family members and it's it's
something else when you really go to
these countries and you see the full
effects of American foreign policy and
you stare a farmer in the eye as he
tells you and shows you all the family
members that your tax dollars financed
that executed them thanks for checking
out this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live don't
forget to subscribe hit the like button
hit the notification Bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for free if you want to listen to us
there thanks for hanging out out and we
will see you all next time